Secretary of State to De to determine
the appeal that's been made by
catsby strategic land limited um
relating to a refusal of planning
permission by molden District Council um
as we know it's an outliner application
for up to 160 dwellings with affordable
housing uh Bungalows office hubs floor
space Children's Day Nursery Associated
parking Community Park
sustainable Urban drainage system and
Associated infrastructure on land north
of the grov Burnham Road lington uh just
the usual reminders please if people
could turn their um telephones on silent
or turn turn them so they don't ring so
we don't get
disturbances um that would be much
appreciated I I haven't been advised
that there's any
um alarm today fire alarm so I assume if
if one goes off we need to evacuate the
building is that
correct thank you and we were advised
earlier in the week that the exit is
there or I think that's the most direct
exit
yeah
um right now um I've the the the what
what we have decided to do following
liaison between the parties is to have a
short session today on um the conditions
in the event I was minded to allow the
appeal and we we've decided to actually
do the closings in writing so um Mr
Willcox will submit his closings by Clos
of play today and um Mr kanuk will then
uh submit his closings tomorrow close of
play um that's to allow the appellant to
have the final word um so we're we're
we're we're with we're still within the
timetable that that was set out we were
we were programmed for um four days so
um once I receive Mr kuks closing
submissions tomorrow we can we'll be in
a position to close the
inquiry so um I hope that's clear to
everybody um as I say today's session
I'm hoping will be reasonably short um
and we're simply going through the
conditions that could be applied where I
minded to allow the
permission uh now I I had to look
through these conditions there do seem
my my initial observations is given that
this is an outlined scheme there do seem
to be an awful lot of conditions and I
do wonder whether some of these could be
um
merged
um in the interests of of clarity and
and and and brevity
um but well I think probably the easiest
way is I understand that the schedule as
it's currently drafted has been agreed
so it's I I I understand that is the
position so I think there was a few
additions from us not nothing
substantial but we went through them in
light of the discussions over the last
two days right there's a a some
additions which we can pick up as we go
through sir okay fine um well the first
one is the first condition is is a
reserve matters standard condition that
um asks for the reserve matters to be
submitted within three years that's a
standard condition
timings again I thought two and three um
almost could potentially be merged
because it seemed to me that some of the
a way of dealing with this would simply
be to have listed all the items that
need to be be submitted as part of a
reserve matters application rather than
having lots of individual
conditions um you know you you could
structure it in such a way that was you
know that Reserve matters shall comprise
the following you know Landscaping
details details of um
boundaries Gates fences etc etc you know
do it that way rather than having lots
and lots of different conditions
that would that would reduce the number
of conditions so so you know if you had
adopted that approach it seems to me you
would
uh you you could reduce things
drastically and reduce the amount of
text as well um I mean I've got no
particular objection to the items that
so I mean Landscaping obviously it is is
fine um car parking is makes sense cycle
parking
is absolutely fine building Heights you
you talk about a 9 M limit um is that
you the sort of is that a twostory house
roughly yeah and the you're happy with
that are you yeah um and then the
dwelling mix um set out in the yeah
that's so the only thing we wanted to
add to that was obviously the offer up
for bungalows yeah which which obviously
is a 10% figure yeah and that would
appear to be the place to
include the requirement for 10% of the
of the dwellings to be to be Bungalows
it fits in quite
nicely yeah okay did also wonder so if
um on reflection if that needed to be a
bit clearer um from the council's
perspective um it's referring obviously
to the local housing needs assessment
but it just says the housing mix
requirement and I'm not sure if it's
absolutely going to be clear what that
housing mix requirement actually is it
may be but I just I
mean is that not dealt with by
the um the the the planning obligation
in any
event I mean I thought the planning
obligation set out the sort of
percentages of it does for the afford it
does I think this is trying to catch the
the open markets I think that actually
that is actually meeting the most up to
date need which I I guess to follow your
line of thinking the council would be
seeking in any event as part of the
reserve matters
so it's p just one for clarification and
with a bungalow addition it probably
just squares a nice Circle yeah okay
that that's fair enough um if you want
to insert that there that's that's
absolutely fine
um
archaeology
um again is a it seems to me a pretty
standard type of uh devel um
condition
biodiversity
um
[Music]
um yeah I mean that's fairly
standard a so we had um S I probably
should introduce myself to the inquir as
I haven't spoken sorry yes um David
Morris I'm planning and operations
director at kesby Estates David Morris
Morris yes Morris okay um at kesby
Estates just to clarify for those um
kesby kesby strategic land limited is
part of kesby Estates so right okay
hence hence kesby Estates um we wondered
there so whether having reviewed this
yesterday evening and there actually and
this may be something we discussed with
the council um there is actually a
biodiversity impact assessment submitted
as part of the application so it should
arguably refer to both documents there
um but that's something we'll discuss
with the with the local Authority in
fact because that's where the um the
metric is as well for BNG and securing
the benefit of the additional BNG versus
the
10% um and it may be that it needs to
refer to that to both documents in that
regard to make sure that the
biodiversity net gain is secured
yeah is that okay with the council
yeah sounds perfectly sensible um
condition 10 um is Great Crested NES
[Music]
um so it's saying any Works which will
impact on the breeding resting place of
great cred nute shall not in any
circumstances commence until the local
planning Authority has been provided
with yeah so it's it's effectively
requiring licensing and so on
um that's seems fair enough
um and then we've got a biodiversity
enhancement strategy that's condition
um I mean again is there any scope for 9
and 11 to be merged given that they sort
of deal with
similar it doesn't good good I mean you
could even you can need add 12 12 I mean
the LM is is part of 11 and and 10 11
anyway I mean it just seems to me that
some of these do duplicate somewhat I
mean it may well be that they needed to
they need to be worded in such a way
sort of to capture all the elements but
they could probably be done in a in a
single condition rather than you know
separately um I mean the biodiversity
stuff I would have thought could could
be
definitely you know you could have a
single condition for that I would have
thought
yeah
um I mean the
lamp is there is there much I suppose
that's landscape and an ecological
management plan I don't know is there is
there much difference between that
and there's lots of different sort of
terminology that's used these days um I
mean one would say probably not if you
look at the criteria for the length they
do pick up most of the yeah but I think
well I'll leave that with you to to to
discuss as with a view to um you know
having a look to see whether they could
be merged in in a in a effective way
that's fine Mak sense
[Music]
um 13 is a lighting scheme um again
that's quite understandable um
so is this a lighting scheme for the
sort of the roads or or for the houses
or for
everything this is for everything my
reading of that linked to the
biodiversity because of the yeah to to
try and minimize the impact yeah
sure
mhm well that seems perfectly fair
enough um drainage condition is number
14 um
that's obviously quite a a technical
type of condition which I assume has
been requested by the flood Authority
yes
um we have a whole series of
flood um conditions don't we
um I assume these are all I mean that 15
is flooding during construction
16 is a flooding maintenance
plan um 17 requires yearly
logs for this is for the drainage system
I assume yes eight 18 is foul water
drainage so sorry to interrupt I had a
query um on 16 it may be that um we need
to just clarify this within the council
um but whether or not 16 should refer to
in perpetuity rather than just a
long-term funding arrangement
details of long-term funding
yeah imp perpetuity
yeah any thoughts Mr Armstrong on your
side on that I think the maintenance
plan will identify effectively it's it's
ongoing maintenance but but if well
maybe we should just say ongoing funding
Arrangements I don't
know I don't think really matters I
think what you're saying is that you you
you you don't want it to to stop you
want it to go on yeah I understand that
from our perspective got problem with
that because ultimately whether it's in
within the management company or
transferred to the Water Authority
whoever it may be that will obviously be
maintain the perpetuity either way so
we're comfortable with
it okay um
well I have no particular preference on
that I mean what if you want to agree a
form of wording it should be should be
okay I mean the as I say there do seem
to again to be a lot of flooding
conditions but they do seem to have I
mean I'm not sure how easy it would be
to merge these because they do seem to
deal with um separate issues the the
only thing I wondered sir is whether 15
in terms of um because effectively it
refers to construction Works whether
that could be incorporated into the
construction management plan
therefore those measures could be within
that document and it covers exactly I I
think that would in some ways would make
more sense if that was included in the
construction management plan because as
you say that's only for the duration of
the construction period so I think
that's a very sensible otherwise it gets
confusing um so yeah good good
point
um so I think that's condition 20 isn't
it the construction management plan yeah
um 19 is the
um uh system of foul
drainage um prior to the first
occupation of any dwelling or building
on site the foul drainage for the
development must be connected to main
main drainage
um
yeah
okay sounds fair enough
um so yes the construction management
plan I mean if there are any other
conditions I mean we'll go we'll go
through them obviously but if there are
any other issues that relate to the
construction period it seems to me that
they would be more
appropriately um included in in in that
in that
particular
um
condition okay
[Applause]
good
[Music]
um right so
20 so 21 is a
contamination um
condition is it is there evidence of
contam contamination on on the
site we know not that I'm aware of so
but what I would say is we've had a
phase one desktop um study done and
therefore in the absence of a phase 2
intrusive survey these tend to be quite
standard conditions um so you would
expect and we would carry this out if
consent was granted that we would carry
out the phase two Geo investigation work
which would then inform these conditions
so that's why I suspect these have been
imposed now
fine okay so I mean the cont
contamination conditions that they look
to be pretty standard yes conditions
um essentially you know if anything
comes to light then remediation strategy
has to be drawn up um fairly standard
approach um as with all these
uh contamination conditions that brevity
isn't their strength they seem to be
very long it's always the same um
so that 23 is also a
contamination condition um
24 is a noise
condition
um yeah is this an environmental health
requirement yes it
is so this is this is for dwellings
facing amenity spaces is
it just seems slightly over the top I
have to say but I mean are we expecting
a lot of
noise there well I mean this is a pretty
I would have thought latchington is not
the most noisy of places is it there are
kennels nearby oh
there okay well any assum I assume that
may be why it was asked for um well I
mean I can understand it if you're sort
of building you know housing on the
Great West Road in London or something
but it's it does seem slightly over the
top but I don't know Mr Armstrong do or
or or Mr Morrison do do you have any
particular view on that I mean if you I
I understand you're happy in principle
with these conditions I I obviously I
have to apply the test as decision maker
as to whether it's necessary you know
and and uh it's not just whether you've
agreed it as it were
yes understood I think um as Mr Coleman
said there are kennels um in the
vicinity and I believe and I might be
wrong here for politics but I believe
third parties may have made uh
representations on that point separately
um so I suspect the environmental health
officer just sort of covering that off
it wasn't raised by the officer as a
point of objection during the
determination of the application so I'd
imagine it would be fairly
straightforward to discharge but I
suspect that's why that may be on then
response to those third party
queries okay well if that's a position
then then that's fair enough
um and then again um 25 is relates to is
again a noise condition that relates to
external plant in respect of any office
or or Nursery building
uh sorry sir my only question on this I
reflected on it is whether in the
absence of detailed design for both of
those whether this was more appropriate
to a reserve matters consent should one
be granted rather than actually having
it now but I'll leave well I mean I do
you
know there there I I do have some
sympathy with with that approach I mean
there are different ways of approaching
outline applications you know you know
I've i' I've had situations where the
council puts on you know 10 conditions
and that's it and they're all quite
Broad and that and and the the
detailed matters are imposed at Reserve
matters stage um and the alternative
approach is is a sort of belt and braces
approach where you you have lots of
detailed conditions so I mean I've got
no strong view on that I I I hear what
you say I mean I don't know uh from your
side um do do you have any
particular observations um well I think
um what what was said before is correct
I think it's in this case because of the
noise it is because of the the kennels
nearby yeah no in terms of whether
that's now or later yeah that's the
issue
really question yeah okay I don't think
we have a strong a strong view sir I
think 25 relates to the nois emitting
from the uses being the office and the
nursery and hence my comment in terms of
that's why it's not um the Ken's point
is covered by
24 I mean I I don't I I've got no strong
views either way on it really
um I mean the point there is that the
council can ask for that work as as part
of the res I mean as they could on a lot
of these issues to be perfectly honest I
accept that and I understand the noise
one I understand that and that ties in
with the noise report we've done but for
the operation of two facilities which
are yet not we don't know what they are
yet and no how they're going to be used
or operated or or whether there's
whatever I think it would certainly that
to reduce the number of conditions that
one could probably yeah I mean obviously
it's it's a bells and braces job I Mr
Coleman I I don't think we well I'm I
don't think we've got any objection to
to leaving it to reserve okay so we
could we could lose that one then okay
um so
26 again is a noise condition that
relates to the we're wondering whether
that one could also be removed sir
because it's it's obviously talking
about what what the future might hold so
what does it say prior to the agreement
the reserve
matters an assessment of noise generated
by the operation of nursery I mean what
again you see that could be put into a
condition re you know the one as I was
saying to you earlier about having a a
reserve matter saying shall comprise the
following items you could say you you
know um an assessment of you could
include that type of thing in in that
condition you know rather than having it
as a freestanding condition that you
know any any uh any reserve you know the
reserve matter shall
comprise d da d an assessment of the
noise generated by the operation of the
proposed Nursery I mean I can see why
you might want that because nurseries
can be quite noisy um you know
particularly with lots of
children um in one place it it can be
quite a a noisy thing so I mean I I
quite see the
um the sort of
uh the reasoning for it but I me I just
wonder whether it be restructured in in
that way we we
we again our discussion was in and
around the reserve matters point because
ultimately the outside play area for a
nursery for example we're not quite sure
yet the orientation of that versus the
residential MH so um therefore we
wondered whether that would be something
that the local Authority would impose at
Reserve matters stage when they then
have a detailed layout for that part of
the development in front of them for
consideration that that makes does make
sense we might need to just double check
the reasoning behind so what you're
happy to take that one out as well well
I think we just need to double check
with colleagues to see why okay if there
was a reason fine I mean do double check
um Mr Coleman I wonder whether I should
take a note of your colleague that's
sitting beside you because sorry I'm
Juliet cotti Juliet cotti how do you
spell that uh k i r k k i r k a l d
y caldi okay um thank you are you one of
the planning officers or yes yeah one of
the planning officers
here did you deal with the application
or no didn't well I I'll just probably
record you in the decision because
obviously you you you've been sort of
participating in this part of the um I
mean what it might be helpful for for
for me actually is if if both sides
could produce a list of um Witnesses and
and participants with their
qualifications just so I know what
what's what that would be that's by
closing yeah I apologize to not
introducing no no I should have I should
have asked at the start to be fair that
who was going to be participating and U
because initially I thought it was just
going to be Mr Coleman and and Mr
Armstrong but then of course Mr Morris
is there and u m coaler c is also there
so um yeah it just for the for the
record I need to list who's
participated
um all right so yeah you're you're going
to take further advice Mr comman on that
I think we've had it I think um we're
happy
to just STI to accept it yeah we we
accept I suppose deferring it to the
reserve matters okay so you happen to
defer
yes okay um now 27
is this is the Office
hub
um you you're you're proposing
restricting the hours of use between 7
and 9 7:00 in the morning and 900 hours
in the evening the appellant is saying
that that's a bit
restrictive
um well
I mean as as as the apparent says I mean
an office use should be you know
that usually office uses are compatible
they're seen as compatible with
residential areas they're not exactly
sir they're not you
know a use that's necessarily going to
cause a nuisance I wouldn't have
thought M I believe this has come from
the environmental health officer
um I don't know any more about the
background is that stand standard
approach yes
standard well I just think it no no work
on Saturdays or Sundays I mean this is
going to be something which is going for
for residents to use for their own
purposes it'll be a a local facility
it's not it's not like a normal office
building where I'd understand you might
want to limit it this is a working from
home type facility indeed and I mean in
a way the other way of looking at it is
is you know when the reserve matters for
the Office hub come in I would have
thought that's probably the more
appropriate time at which to look at the
the the nature of the building and what
what what restrictions may or may not be
yes appropriate I mean yeah because
we've we've provided these Elsewhere on
other sites and um for example Parish
councils have taken up occupation of the
office subub for part of part of the
time in terms of their meetings of than
evenings and weekends so it offers that
flexibility therefore yeah I mean it
seems to me that that that that that it
does for given this is an outline
application this does seem to be a bit
um detailed really for for this for this
stage just double- cheing but I can't
see why we wouldn't defer that to the
reserve matters I mean that seems to be
a more logical approach you know that
you would assess the Reser you know the
The Office hub as when it comes in as it
were you would then make an assessment
as to what would be the appropriate time
restrictions if if any or what noise
restrictions you might want to impose
rather than at this stage yeah no yeah I
agree with that we are just just just
confirming so apologies
okay there is an obligation so this is
different to the nursery in terms of an
obligation to provide it so within the
106 agreement there is actually an
obligation to deliver this as part of
the scheme and therefore clearly that
will be applied for within the reserve
matters for the development okay yeah
then we've had confirmation that's
absolutely fine okay so so defer to
reserve matters
yeah
okay so
28 um Waste
Management I mean again that's probably
one that could be included in the you
know the reserve matters condition that
shall comprise the following items you
know details of a waste management
plan rather than having that as a
freestanding condition
similarly uh well we've already had a
lighting condition haven't we number 29
the previous one is more related to
biodiversity I
think yeah with query this before and I
believe that's the response we had a few
weeks ago was the two are different in
that
regard I think the ecological officer
wanted a separate one for biodiversity I
believe but we'll leave that to the
council well it seems to me that you
know
if it's a lighting scheme you know it's
a lighting scheme and and it and it
needs to be designed to take into
account bi A diversity it seems
ridiculous to have two sort of parallel
requirements um I mean I I would have
thought you you would have a single
condition that would say you know a
lighting scheme taking account of
biodiversity
issues yeah I I I mean you know what
You' you you because presumably you'd
want to in you know why would you want
two conditions covering the same topic
essenti yeah no I I absolutely agree
we're just double- checking but yeah
absolutely
agree okay
um
deliveries
um this I did think this seemed like a
rather odd condition because I
mean that that could potentially prevent
any deliveries to any of the houses yeah
I think we were either thinking it needs
to be deleted or specifically re refer
to the nursery or office separately or
whether such a condition for deliveries
to the nursery office would be imposed
at Reserve matters consent
MH well I I think to be honest it's a
it's it's an unenforceable condition to
be honest with you and it I mean it
potentially would would apply to all the
dwellings you know that they they
couldn't get Amazon deliveries you know
at certain times of the day which which
would clearly be ridiculous
so I think that one would have will have
to go I'm afraid although I see it says
no do not
delete in red I think that was to do
with clarifying that the intention is
that it covers the the whole of the
development as opposed to just a
construction period and but I I agree
I I yeah I mean I I I just to me that
seems like a a condition that
is it's it's an unenforceable condition
I mean I could understand if we were
dealing with some sort of industrial
complex where you had large lorries
coming
in and you know unloading and loading
and so on but it that would apply
effectively to the entire development
which would preclude even the
residential units from getting
deliveries which which is
clearly wrong I mean if if it seemed to
be necessary in you know in in respect
of The Office
hub to
have you know certain restrictions again
that's a matter that can be dealt with
down the line as it were so I I think
that one my my view on that is that it's
it's just an unenforceable condition
yeah we're we're happy with that um
happy for anything to be raised that
Reserve matter stage if say to do with
the office use or otherwise
yeah um so 31 is a tree
condition um looks pretty standard to me
yeah
um 32 is a Broadband condition
requiring
um provision of um super fast broadb
band again it's quite common um these
days and I think it it is's a policy in
the local plan that requires that so
that's seems to be fair enough yep
um 33 is a conservation
um
condition requiring
um what it says prior to the first
occupation of any building on site
details of the position design and
content of the proposed interpretation
board relating to the pillbox and its
historical contact shall be
provided um and approved in writing by
the local planning
Authority um i' I've got no particular
problem with that I mean that we've
agreed that seems to be perfectly
acceptable
highways uh so we've got
um the this is the access for the
northern parcel number
34 which um it just gives the details of
of
how um how that should be provided and
it is required prior to the first
occupation I think the the drawing
numbers are a little a little bit behind
the curve so okay we'll make sure if we
make sure they're um are included um and
then the
the well 36 is is is a similar condition
for the southern parcel of the
land again we need to make sure that the
plan is is
correct um 35 is the implementation of a
zebra
[Music]
Crossing um
um I
mean just would this be provided but
would this how would this be actually
affected would it would it be affected
by the highway Authority and the and and
the developer would pay or so it would
be carried out using section 278 works
as per sort of off-site Highways
requirements um under Section 278 our
only comments are there is in relation
to what's in bra at the bottom as to
whether or not that's really needed
within their because ultimately a
commuted sum would be provided as part
of the section 278 process anyway I
think that condition might need to be re
worded
slightly because I mean for a start the
that is sort of more of an advisory that
bit in Brackets it's not really a
condition yeah um and I think it perhaps
the condition needs to make clear
that you know obviously
the element that requiring that it's
provided prior to First occupation is
fine but
um maybe maybe we need to refer to
section 278 you know that it would
be it would be affected through the
process because I mean would that
essentially mean that the highway
Authority would actually build it and
then the money would be provided by the
developer it means that you're also
relying on them build it before you can
exactly yeah which is I think the only
problem is referring to you then have an
agreement on an agreement then wouldn't
you which would which would be could be
complicated I mean I I think it would be
easy just to take out what's in the
brackets yeah because the reality is we
need those 278 well maybe we should just
say prior to the occupation of the
development a zebra Crossing shall be
provided in accordance with d d d that
do it that way yeah absolutely so that
would just make sure that it's provided
and then it's up to to the you know on
between
parties that would probably be a way of
dealing with that rather than saying the
developer shall Implement because that's
not strictly that's true it's a good
point yes not not strictly right is
it okay um oh Sor sorry apparently your
microphone's off sorry thank you I'm
probably not being broadcast to the
world then if I'm if I'm not on yeah so
just to to reiterate I said
that the zebra Crossing shall be
provided prior to the first occupation
of the development um rather than saying
the developer shall provide because it's
not actually the the developer who will
implement the works they may well pay
for the works but they're not actually
getting out there with their Spades and
digging the road as it
were right good okay well 36 we dealt
with that was the northern sorry that's
the southern access
um and
37 now this one I yeah I wasn't sure
about this one because it says prior to
the first occupation of the Southern
parcel of the development the applicant
shall submit a scheme for
approval for the provision of two new
bus stops is is that something that the
applicant would do or is that something
that would
be it would be done in conjunction with
because whil we've
shown theoretically where those bus
stops are going to be the exact position
of them will be something we'll have to
discuss with the with the highway
Authority in the bus is it is it the
highway Authority or is it the bus
services I think they all get involved
if it's on Highway land and there's a a
bus operator it'll be is that a matter
for the local planning authority to
approve though if it's a bus stops I
mean I don't know I didn't know that
that local authorities get involved with
bus stops I think because the 106 has a
contribution towards improving bus
services past the site I think in order
to ensure that there was another bus
stop within a closer vicinity of the
scheme that's why that had been
requested because the two go in in
tandem as it were right okay well I I if
that's the case I mean
uh it's I understand um why why it's
need
did okay that's that's fine
um so yeah I mean what would be helpful
is if if as I say if you could
perhaps redraft these in the light of
the discussion that we've had um and and
yes apologies there is one that we've
forgotten and apologies I don't
particularly want to add another
condition but we've already discussed
the approved plans oh position thank you
for reminding me yes of course and as in
a lack of them um and Jeff you've got
the list there so it's probably worth
you reading them out but effectively
they cover the site accesses location
plan and framework plan site access
um if it's easier so it's in appendix
one common ground it's those four yeah
no we you're quite right we we I this is
something I mentioned um when we were
dealing with the evidence that that
clearly there does need to be
fundamental condition that that ties the
the any scheme to the the site you know
the actual site plan the including the
the site accesses I mean I'm wondering
whether the those two
conditions uh well no I suppose they're
requiring the provision before
occupation aren't they so that that
that's slightly different but yeah no I
mean we certainly need an approved plans
condition so that that should
be up near the beginning it should um
can I just um also flag I think it was
I'm sure it was raised yesterday and by
Mr kuk and and I think it been raised
before as well um but in the statement
of Common Ground um there is a paragraph
that just explains the position around
the various plans that were submitted
right um because essentially there there
were plans submitted but weren't
necessarily part of the determination
right so it's paragraph 3.8 of the
statement of Common Ground just
clarifies that position so I don't think
we we have any major issues or well I
think we discussed this at the the case
management conference the the the the
amendment didn't we I I seem to recall
and I think Mr Johnson who was on the
call uh the head of development control
development management um confirmed that
he he was happy with the substitution of
any plans that was my understanding of
it wasn't around the substitution of
plans that I think that was agreed this
was around what was actually part of the
the application that was submitted right
so as I said it the the position is
summarized in in paragraph
3.8 well I haven't actually got that to
hand at the moment so do you want do you
want to just read it out yeah certainly
yeah um so it says a schedule setting
out the documents and drawings that were
submitted by the applicant is contained
at appendix one while this indicates
that drawing number A1 a121 B which is
the framework master plan was submitted
for approval the application itself
indicates that the only matters for
which approval is being sought um as
part of the outline application relate
to access as a result the council has
determined the application on the basis
that the framework master plan provides
indicative information on the likely
spatial parameters for the proposed
development proposed condition one in
the officer's report makes clear the
details of the appearance Landscaping
layout and scale are to form part of
Reserve matters applications to follow
in addition the decision notice issued
by the council makes no reference to
drawing number A1 121b which is the
framework master plan so what's it in a
in a nutshell what what's the point that
that you're making well the point there
is just around what was actually what
the council was determining with it
determin the
application and the status of those
plans I don't think we I think we we
understand the need to the logic in
referring to the framework master plan I
just wanted so you're saying that that
wasn't before members I believe it was
before members it just wasn't wasn't P
part of the application part of the
submission which just wasn't referenced
in the committee report yeah right to
members but it's always been part of
this it's part of the reconsultation we
did and it's been part of the appeal
way through so it's a plan which people
are aware of and and clearly it's it's
it's the best way which we can then
secure the delivery of the open space
which we talked about yesterday also
identifies the location of The Office
hub and the I mean I'm not quite clear
Mr Comm what your are you saying that
they shouldn't be included then or what
are you saying I think I'm I'm just
raising the the I raising the fact that
I don't think that they were determined
by the Council in the I don't think when
the council determined the application
that that that they were necessarily
aware of the status of those plans so if
they were only considering outl that the
application was outline
only um with um so outline only looking
at access then they they may not have
realized that they were determining that
plan as the framework master plan I mean
I would have thought their concerns were
more the principle of the development of
the site rather than you know any
framework
mean I don't think their
decision was was I mean I can't speak
for the committee but it seems to me
that they were that their fundamental
problem with it was the fact that you
know there's 160 houses proposed on an
area that's currently a green field that
was their problem you know uh well I
mean it seems to me a matter that you
need to to resolve but it seems to me
that we do need to have some um means of
of tying down any you know in the event
I was minded to allow the appeal we need
to have some means of tying the
development down and I I I mean I think
it it it was helpful that the appellant
Mr Armstrong
agreed earlier on in in the sessions
that you know they that they were happy
to have some kind of framework plan that
that secured the the
Eastern um Landscaping buffer because it
seems to me if we don't include that
then frankly um it's all it's worse for
the for the council if it's included I
think it's more just wanted to flag it
up procedurally that I don't know that
that
was you know identified in that way at
the time in the application but I think
we agree that it's useful it's
beneficial to tie down those land uses
no I mean I think given that that's the
way the application was submitted the
the more any permission is you know tied
down obviously a lot of Mr milre
evidence was was was predicated on this
notion of a of of an Eastern you know
buffer um now my concern was that you
know if there's no plan included in any
condition then that that's not that
wouldn't be secured
yeah so agree
that yeah okay yeah just sorry just to
add what I would say is in the plan
planning balance section of the
officer's report um in paragraph 5.4
apologies sir I don't have the core
document reference to hand the officer
does state that one of the main benefits
of The Proposal are the environmental
benefits of the development as a result
of the enhancement and provision of
landscape and ecological features so
it's clearly in there from
a a benefit point of view in that regard
yeah I mean I would have thought as I
say were I minded to allow the appeal it
would be
you know to the
council's advantage to to have the
development tied down in a way that
would ensure some sort of buffer rather
than having no having not having it
included no we we agree with that sir
yeah and and we support that as well
okay good all right well I'll I'll leave
that um with you then um I don't know
how long you want um to how long you
need to to to work on the shed schedule
I mean I'm happy to give you a few days
if that if needs be I mean just
Wednesday next week to to submit it is
that is that too
[Music]
far that's yeah I mean we're quite
flexible so up to you guys if you so
Friday of next week yes yeah okay
agreed that gives you over a week so it
should should be enough time I would
have thought I mean to be honest you you
know a lot of the changes although it
probably sounds like a a complete
rewrite I mean I think it should should
be reasonably um straightforward to do
it would be helpful as well if if they
obviously if they can be emailed to Mr
Wordsworth at the at planning
inspectorate um that so I have an
electronic copy of it that would be most
helpful the council will add that to the
portal that's I'm yeah okay Johnny good
[Music]
um all right so that that deals with the
conditions
um I'm in terms of the legal agreement
um I I don't particularly have
any
comments um I don't know if
it
it's it essentially
um I think Mr kuks opening submissions
he he sets out in in his opening
submissions you know the various matters
that would would be
secured by the obligation and and so
that it seems to
me um Rel atively clear you there's a
there's a schedule relating to
affordable housing which requires that
not more not less than 50% of the
dwellings sh shall be provided as
affordable housing and it gives a split
of of how the dwellings are to be
provided in terms of social rented
housing and intermediate housing and
there's a lot
of uh technical detail on nomination
rights and so on um so that's the afford
housing
element the there's a provision relating
to um local open space um again
requiring uh that to be provided as part
of any proposal and there's Provisions
relating to the maintenance of that open
space
um there's also uh requirement for a
local open space specification and local
open space maintenance plan
um there's also Provisions relating to
the day Nursery that um that should be
provided um
that the developer and owner Covenant to
market the day nursery and use
reasonable Endeavors to enter into a
binding contract with prospective end
users um of the day nursery for a period
of 12 months
um and then it's as I understand it if
it's not provided within that period
Then it it reverts to local open space
is that
essentially that's correct sir
yeah
[Music]
um uh and then we have a schedule on
first
homes um sir sorry can I just raise on
the on the fourth schedule which is um
just before it's got two items one is
the S6 Ram S6 Coast Rams and one is the
contribution to V NHS mhm I just noticed
that the esss coast Rams contribution
isn't specified and I think everything
else in the document
is so I just didn't know if that needed
to be added sorry it's not expressed the
the the actual contribution itself it
doesn't say what it is how much it is
ah it just says the contribution oh okay
is that not defined in
the is it defined cont depend on
number but in the other case is where
that's it it is defined uh some
comprising
15676 per dwelling as a contribution
towards the mitigation of the harm
caused to those sites detected by the
habitats regulations okay thank
you okay
um and then schedule five deals with
first
homes um so there's a series of
definitions in that
section um
I've not got any particular comment on
that
um and then the uh moving on to the
sixth schedule is a requirement for a
residential travel
plan
um so this is a a travel plan is
essentially uh a a plan to incl include
measures to ensure sustainable means of
travel are available to residents of the
development fairly standard requirement
in new residential
developments
um so nothing to say on that um and then
we have the bus service
contribution which um requires a payment
for to the County Council for bus
services
um sorry so what what I would um add on
that point I think Mr kanuk um when
we're having the discussion around the
openings mentioned that we may have had
some concern on the bus service
contribution I think yeah um we didn't
have a concern per se it was more in the
absence of the charging schedu document
that we hadn't seen the text that went
in that into terms of how it was spent
um and I can confirm we're perfectly
happy with that now having okay that's
helpful thank
you and then the seventh schedule
relates to education
contributions
um so that sets out what contributions
would be payable I assume these are all
agreed with the relevant
authorities
um and then
the we have the library
contribution um which
is uh a sum per
dwelling that will be paid again I
presume to the County
[Applause]
Council and then the eighth schedule
relates to the office Hub and um that is
required to be constructed before 80% of
the dwellings are
provided
so yeah I mean as I understand it the
the provisions are essentially agreed
between the the various parties so I've
I've got you know no further comments on
that really um Ju Just in terms of the
status of it so it's been signed by the
land owners by kby um and County Council
um and therefore it's just a district to
sign and
and I'm assuming bearing in mind you
have no comments that that will happen
in the next day or so but or whenever
the there's no again I mean I don't know
whether it has to be signed by the mayor
or something sometimes these things take
sealing process takes time but I mean um
given that
you're you've you've agreed to provide
the conditions within a week I I I'm I'm
happy to
Grant at least a week I mean if you need
longer than that then then let me
no sorry sir um just been flagged up to
to me um that there may be an
admission have contribution okay I think
it is there so just bear with me one
minute
poy the NHS contribution is defined in
the
front I mean if you if you want to just
liaz with each other outside this forum
as it were if there's any particular I
mean I I had a read through it last
night and there was nothing that sort of
jumped out at me as being erroneous but
I mean if you if you by all
means if there are any sort of texting
sorry any text that needs to be
tightened up or or whatever then that
that that's
fine I I mean as I see it's the the main
Provisions are are are clear and so that
you know that's as long as the the
fundamental Provisions remain the same
you know if there's changing to the
wording or whatever that that's
absolutely fine and we I think you've
provided a s compliance statement which
sets out why these things
are
necessary so um yeah good there sorry
sir there there are a couple of changes
we need to make to the sil compliance
statement so somebody's looking at those
okay well I mean if if that can be sent
to me certainly um in due course that
would be that would be helpful for
absolutely yeah so sorry just to
ask sorry do do we know do we know which
areas that there may be changes in the
the issue that was raised was I think to
do with the health contribution and that
as I see it is in section four yeah so I
think I think it was um I think it's
fine I don't think there is an issue
right oh sorry on the S compliance
statement apologies sorry sorry no no
um but I just noticed when I looked at
it last night um page seven I mean it's
a copy and paste error as opposed to a
major issue I believe but it's Financial
contribution to the
library um it then refers in in the
third column to Secondary School places
so it just needs to be um double checked
that that row that talks about Library
provision there's a a couple of
references to secondary provision
secondary educ ation provision I see
mean in the middle column and at the end
of the First Column as
well all right well look I I'll I'll
leave you to to rather than take up
inquiry time I'll I'll I'll leave you to
to to sort that out between you as long
as the the C compliance statement
explains why um you know certain
contributions have been asked for and
you know that's that's all I need really
so if there's certain details you need
to resolve then I'll need you to do that
merely simple admin from what nothing
major I I seem to have been provided it
looks as if these are the comments are
these the comments of the uh changing
the subject um the latchington parish
council comments so you wanted a copy my
so I've given you a copy in the council
yeah no thank you very much uh Mr
Armstrong I'll give that an inquiry
document number um I'm not quite sure
what number we're up to but um that OB
wasn't I think that was in your
examination wasn't it um you you raised
the point about the comments that they'
made and I don't think they were
previously before the inquiry they were
merely summarized in the officer's
report so thank you for that
um are there any other procedural points
anyone wants to raise um now uh I'll
just uh so reiterate the council's
agreement yesterday to provide with the
details of the residents who offered
views from their Gardens that I haven't
forgotten that I just haven't it just
isn't done yet thank you that deal with
Mr wal Cox I I will um arrange a site
visit in due course I'm certainly not
proposing to do it today in these these
conditions I I I'll um yes if you if you
provide the case officer with um the
details of any any residents that want
wanted me to view it from from their
property that would that would be very
help helpful and I'm happy to do that
with the appellant agreement
unaccompanied and I'll I'll make it
clear to to those whose property I visit
that I will not be open to hearing any
submissions from them that that was a
message I stressed in the discussion as
well yes indeed um and so I I've I've
seen a note which is going to be
circulated from Mr milc on the site
visit itinerary so that that can be
circulated as well yes thank you Mr kuk
for that um that would be most helpful
if if a site route as it were could
could be provided um for me to follow
that that would be quite very helpful
umk sorry sorry sir just apologies for
interrupting the only comment we've got
is in relation to that is um as the land
is obviously farmed um so that we're
copied into the correspondence to Mr
wwth in terms of the details and the
dates just so I can inform the land
owner that you'll be on site and Gates
can be left Al is there any are there
any uh sort of cows or anything on the
side at the moment is arabel isn't it
yes I did a site recent recent a recent
site visit where I was confronted with a
sort of herd of cows charging towards me
which was was wasn't particularly
Pleasant not conducive to I I assumed
that it was it was sort of predominantly
arable yeah no
no um no it it's
you you sort of hear these terrible
stories of people being trampled to
death so uh want to try and avoid that
are there any other risks I should be
aware of on site uh no not the word no
no no but as I understand it Mr Morris
you're happy for me if I need to to to
go on the the site correct yeah thank
you it is um no doubt after today and
yes so I'll take I'll take a good pair
of I always K car winton's in wington
Boots in in in the car for for these
purposes okay well thank you very much
um as I
said in opening this morning we've
agreed that the closing submissions will
be done in writing I I don't think that
puts anyone at a disadvantage I've asked
the council to ensure that the um the
closings are uploaded onto the council's
website so that they will be available
for um everyone who's interested to read
essenti they that what the the closing
submissions do is they just Summarize
each party's argument so Mr can uh Mr
Willcox will will put his in first and
then um the appellant as is as as is the
tradition in these situations will uh
put their um their their submissions in
afterwards and uh that's been agreed uh
so that's very helpful so are there any
other points anyone wants to raise Mr
Willcox or or Mr Mr kenck no sir other
than on behalf of both parties thank you
for allowing melan friend and I a degree
of latitude in presenting our cases I
think it's allowed us to deal with
things uh very quickly if I may say so
um and thank you for allowing us to get
it done so so quickly um I apprciate
absolutely Echo those those comments
well thank you Mr kanak and Mr Wilcox
for your contributions you've been
extremely helpful in in facilitating the
inquiry in a in a in a in a a very
efficient way so I thank you both for
that and I also thank all the
participants that have Mr Comm Mr
Armstrong Mr Morris and people who have
attended as well thank you for showing
an interest um I I I as I said to you
all earlier I'm very aware of um the
there's a lot of objection on this
particular scheme so I will obviously be
considering everyone's
objections uh very carefully and um
before reaching a decision so but thank
you all for your your contributions over
the last few days um once I've received
all the outstanding documents um I'll
I'll then proceed to a decision in in in
due course I can't give you a firm uh
outline as as to time timings at this
stage but um hopefully um um I'll I'll
be able to do that in due course U once
I've received all the
documents so that will conclude
proceedings in the chamber today
um so thanks all for coming and um I
will close the inquiry formally in
writing once I've received the the
various
documents so thank you all again and
uh I'll adjourn rather than close the
inquiry um and I thank you all for for
attending thank you thank you
sir